un enfant sur dix est victime de
harcèlement scolaire
en plus de faire preuve de vigilance il
est nécessaire de faire de la prévention
dans les cours de récréation des écoles
élémentaires de plaisir des banques bien
identifiables ont fait leur apparition
au mois de décembre
j'ai une dispute qui était m'asseoir sur
le banc puis après y'a quelqu'un qui est
venu pour qu'on joue ensemble car ce
banc vert est un banc de l'amitié
inspiré par une école privée du
département la ville de plaisir a
souhaité l'installer dans toutes ses
écoles le fait d'avoir à bord de
l'amitié ça permet à des enfants d'avoir
un lieu repères pour se positionner pour
s'y asseoir et faire comprendre aux
autres sans forcément le verbaliser
qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas
plus que le harcèlement ce banc est un
outil de lutte contre l'isolément dont
les enfants se sont déjà saisies
la demande de ce bord avait même été
faite par un jeune de cet établissement
scolaire il ya quelques années pour les
collégiens de montigny le bretonneux
nartuby
la prévention passe aussi par le théâtre
la ville a établi un partenariat avec
les établissements depuis une dizaine
d'années ils suivent des ateliers sur le
bien vivre ensemble tout au long de leur
scolarité
la séance de débat théâtral intervient
une fois par an pour les classes de 4e
les équipes enseignantes non le dise
aujourd'hui qu'en fait les jeunes
viennent plus parler ce pas forcément
les jeunes qui sont victimes mais voilà
les amis l'entourage ils vont aller plus
par les verts le ver l'adulte ils ont un
peu plus conscience des personnes
référentes autour d'eux au programme
quatre scènes représentant des
situations de harcèlement
les adolescents sont ensuite invités à
monter sur scène pour entrer dans la
peau d'un personnage et corriger les
comportements les adultes encadrant les
établissements nous disent comme un
petit miracle parce qu'ils voient leurs
élèves d'une manière différente
finalement est-ce que les élèves
viennent pas à faire passer leur message
à travers des personnages
la magie opère les jeunes improvisent
avec les comédiens et trouve les
solutions pour éviter les situations de
harcèlement de la mise à l'écart à cause
d'un physique ou d'une tenue
vestimentaire au cyber harcèlement
toutes les thématiques sont abordées
j'ai bossé avec avec kenza
elle se faisait harceler alice faire
agresser et je les bus conduit une fois
le spectacle terminé les enseignants
sont amenés à poursuivre le travail
objectif amener les jeunes à parler